I think the real the scourge the disease
the infection in the modern church today
is moral cowardice this is our great
problem moral cowardice we are a Church
of cowards and we can think of all the
excuses that we want to explain away the
problems that we're seeing but when it
comes down to it I think if we look
around us we can see plain as day that
it is cowardice
not not only cowardice that is one of
the main problems that we face is our
own cowardice now in my piece yesterday
I wrote about this and I used by way of
contrast the story of John the Baptist a
story that I hope is still well-known
and and and famous among Christians and
non-christians but John the Baptist as
as you probably are aware was not afraid
to call sin by its name it wasn't afraid
to call sin out to call people to
repentance that was what he did that was
his mission so when when Herod invited
him to the palace and confided in him
and spoke with him John told
Herod the truth he just told him a
simple truth that's all he told Herod
that divorcing his wife and taking his
brother's wife was a sin and for
speaking the plain truth and nothing but
the truth he was thrown in jail and then
of course eventually executed and that's
how his head ended up on a platter he
died because he denounced immorality he
called it out and not just any mo in any
immorality but but it was sexual
immorality and so I think most American
Christians they would look at that and
they would probably say if they were if
they were consulting with John the
Baptist or they were around back then
with with the attitude they have now
they would say to John the Baptist well
it's none of your business but I mean
you don't get involved in that it's none
of your business don't be so judgmental
love is love after all don't you realize
John if Herod wants to get rid of his
wife and and commits adultery with his
brother's wife and so what what do you
care leave and let live
take it easy John I think that's what
the modern Christian would say but
that's not the view that John the
Baptist took he didn't he didn't see it
the way he looked at sin and he saw sin
as something
disgusting and toxic and lethal he saw
it as something that ha it harms not
only the person who's committing the sin
but it also harms everybody else how
everybody who comes in contact with it
is harmed by it there really is no such
thing as a sin that's only that's that's
kind of especially a sin that is that
other people can see other people can
witness those kinds of sin are not just
are never just harmful to the person
doing them they're harmful to everyone
who sees it because of the effect in
this scandal and the way that it might
normalize the sin in a person's mind or
make it seem not quite as bad
so from John's perspective any sin had
to be called out had to be identified
had to be condemned had to be pulled up
from the roots and destroyed and so John
the Baptist was
extremely extremely intolerant he was a
man of extreme intolerance and so it's
interesting then to note that Jesus
Christ said that of all the men of all
the mortal men on earth none have been
greater than John the Baptist
Jesus Christ identified John the Baptist
as the greatest man
and yet John the Baptist was very
intolerant and he was even what what
today we would call a doomsday preacher
preaching Hellfire right and yet Jesus
Christ says this was the greatest man
which really seems like I mean it seems
like a ringing endorsement of John's
whole approach of his it seems like a
ringing endorsement of John's intolerant
approach that Jesus Christ said this is
the greatest man so let's look at our
case then while John the Baptist died in
his for his defense of sexual morality
for his defense of moral truth
Christian's today in America and in
throughout the West have given up
we've given up our defense on both
fronts and for really no reason there's
we're not we're not facing any kind of
real violent persecution but if you look
at the polls you'll see that a majority
of Christians endorse same-sex marriage
divorce fornication and on and on in
fact all of our
all of all of the most popular sins in
our society Christians are fine with
them even even abortion has the approval
of wide swaths of of American Christians
and I'm not look I'm not complaining
that because Christians struggle with
these things that's not the point
something like sexual immorality that's
always gonna be a struggle people have
always struggled with that since the
beginning of time but that's that's not
our problem our problem is actually the
opposite of that our problem is that we
aren't struggling we don't struggle we
decide we've simply declared that these
things are okay we've stopped struggling
there is no struggle we've decided
the most popular sins our favorite sins
aren't sins anymore so there's no
struggle
there's no repentance there's no it's
one thing for us to sin and then to say
oh my god what have I done forgive me
help me
that's one thing it's another thing to
sin and say it's fine I'm fine
that doesn't matter it's just you know
whatever this is how I want to live my
life
yeah and I'm in a personal relationship
with Jesus and in my relationship Jesus
doesn't care about this
okay because I've made up my own rules
in my personal relationship
it's my personal relationship have you
noticed that many times when somebody I
don't wanna get this is kind of a
separate topic but when somebody cites
their personal relationship with Jesus
they'll often do it in a defensive way
because they're kind of lackadaisical
approach to religion has been called
into question and then what they'll say
notice the antic because there's nothing
wrong with the concept of a personal
relationship with Jesus in fact of
course we should all have a personal
relationship with Jesus in that our
relationship we should we should it
should be a an affectionate intimate
relationship that we have with with with
Jesus it should be marked by love and by
a deep knowledge and understanding right
so there should be a personal
relationship but if you notice when many
times when people use this phrase
notice the emphasis
a lot of time what they'll say is well
this is my personal relationship with
Jesus this is my personal relationship
with Jesus the emphasis on my like this
is something that I own it's mine it's
on my terms I make the rules I set the
terms
and also notice that you know you go
back to the Middle Ages go back to
medieval times
[Music]
this idea of a personal relationship
with Jesus that phrase didn't exist
nobody said that yet Christian's back
then had a very intimate almost mystical
connection to God you look at gogo read
st. Augustine's Confessions read how
just intimate that is Christians today
can't even conceive of God on those
kinds of terms
yet that's how that's how st. Augustine
was connected with God and not through
this idea of a personal relationship
that didn't there wasn't any of that
and I think and I think that this phrase
although it speaks to a certain truth it
has led some people astray
because it gives them in the impression
of this is a relationship that they have
ownership over
anyway so how do we account for this
is it is it ignorant is that all it is
but people don't understand if you talk
to the average Christian and they say
yeah whatever gay marriage divorce
abortion let me do what you want it's
all fine
are they really ignorant
are they really not they really have no
understanding was or do they really
think that the the biblical commands
have some kind somehow expired do they
really think that yeah I mean a thousand
years ago or two thousand years ago this
stuff was immoral it's not anymore
because times have changed somehow and
moral truths have just evolved somehow
is that really what Christians think
maybe some of them do
but I think I think most of them if
they're fooled it's because they fooled
themselves
and so I think in most cases it's simply
a case of cowardice
and I really have to wonder
has there ever been a society
plagued with so many Christians who are
so unwilling to defend even the most
basic teachings of their faith
has ever been a Christian society that
just cowered so completely under a
threat that really is not severe at all
I mean what are we what are we actually
worried about what's what's that what's
the punishment that awaits us if we
stand up and declare the truth that we
stand up and speak out forcefully for
moral truth if we draw the line and say
no that's wrong this is wrong this is
right okay and here's the line if we do
that what's gonna happen to us what are
we worried about
all the people who are so meek and mild
and quiet
and refused to say anything what are
they worried is going to happen to them
a reward that that maybe will will will
lose some friendships that were
meaningless anyway French if it's a
friendship that you're gonna lose if you
actually speak your mind then that's not
a real friendship who cares about that
friendship it's worthless let it go so
is that what we're worried about gonna
lose some friends maybe we're gonna
things gonna be awkward in the family
because we got there's some people in
the family don't agree with us we don't
want to set them who cares so what
so what are we worried about worst-case
scenario we might say well we will lose
our jobs
we'll lose our jobs if we were if we
were serious Christians and if we speak
out then we'll lose our job look okay
that's um that's a more severe penalty I
suppose but in the grand scheme of
things what does that even matter
in 50 years most of the people watching
this or listening to this right now
myself included most of us will probably
be dead in 50 or 60 years
and what's that kind of matter then you
were able to hold on to a job who cares
can't bring it with us into the next
stage
all this some financial security that we
were able to attain for ourselves and
hold on to by remaining silent in the
face of cultural decay
well what good is that going to be is
that is your financial security gonna
mean anything when you're standing
before Judgment Day
there's something else to keep in mind
here when I when I you know when I
highlight the fact that so many
Christians are terrified of denouncing
sin against the sins against marriage
sins sins of sexual immorality and so
forth I'm not saying that our primary
job as Christians is to oppose gay
marriage or whatever that's that's not
my point
my point is that our culture has
selected certain sins and put them up on
a pedestal
and then literally thrown them a parade
and said this is wonderful everybody
applauded this is the greatest thing
let's celebrate
and when our culture is doing that when
it's literally throwing parades for sins
and demanding that we celebrate and
applaud certain sins then I think we as
Christians have a choice to make
we can we have two options we can either
number one go along with it and applaud
politely and say oh yes isn't this
wonderful yeah so yes yes yes love is
love
III can't judge you mustn't judge you
mustn't judge no no judgement yes yes
wonderful
so we can do that
or the second option is that we can
I refuse to applaud
and say no this isn't right
there's there are there are things that
are morally true and morally untrue this
is and and I'm going to stand with the
moral truth
this isn't right I'm not going to
applaud it this is sin
and I think choosing that latter option
which is the correct option it's as much
about opposing the particular sin itself
as it is about the basic principle the
basic principle that we're gonna be
honest and we're going to speak the
truth no matter the topic so John the
Baptist a vet died essentially because
he denounced this the sin of herod's but
it's not like it's not like denouncing
Herod's the the the sin of Herod's
marriage and divorce and adultery it's
not like that was John the Baptist
greatest mission on earth it's not like
that was the primary thing he was
concerned about and it's not as though
he wanted to die over that
but it was just the truth that's all
and so he died for the truth it's not
like he wanted to die over that
particular issue but he was willing to
die over the truth plain and simple
and when the truth is attacked
I think we have to stand up in defense
of truth
it's not even really specifically
defense of this issue although it is
that but even more important it's just a
defense in principle of truth
and that is worth
ever the the penalty maybe for it
one other point here I think that
our refusal to denounce sin to call out
sin that's one symptom of our cowardice
but I don't think it's the the primary
symptom it's not the worst symptom the
greatest symptom I think is that Chris
is just the general fact that
Christianity that faith in America has
been kind of pushed out onto the fringes
of existence with our permission and
many times with our help
faith has just been pushed to the side
we've allowed our faith to be to be
severed almost completely from what we
consider to be normal life and we've
allowed it to be relegated to these just
sort of corners of society
we have as I put on my piece yesterday
we are a population of Christians yet we
have built for ourselves an atheist
society and now we use the secularism of
society as an excuse to be secular
ourselves
and so if you want proof of our
cowardice I would say that is the
number-one proof right there it's not
any one particular issue it's not any
one particular sin it's just look around
you in your everyday life and there is
almost no evidence of Christianity in
our culture as you go about your life
we're all just walking around and living
as if there is no God
and that is that's many things but it is
also cowardice so we could talk all we
want about there was you know the the
reclaiming faith in America the
resurgence of faith in America but
there's not going to be any resurgence
unless there's a resurgence of courage
in the church
I don't think we can't it's good for us
to pray it's good for us to ask for
God's assistance
but I think if we're expecting a miracle
if we're expecting God to come in and
kind of like bail us out
and to come in by divine miraculous
intervention and to save our culture
from the from final self-destruction if
we're waiting for that if we're hoping
for that
I think we're hoping in vain I don't
think God's going to do that
because even if and I could be wrong I
can't speak to what God will do and
won't do
um but I do know historically speaking
when when a society gets the point where
it's just rejected God and it's
careening over the edge usually that's
when God says alright have it your way
you've you've made your point you don't
want me okay
and now your whole society is going to
be destroyed because you destroyed it
now you're going to reap what you sow
and I think the reason why God at a
certain point has to say that is because
even if he did come in by divine
intervention and rescue us from the
cliff and set us on the right path again
even if he did that
because most of us are a bunch of
cowards we would just lose we would
quickly lose whatever whatever was
gained by divine intervention anyway so
we would have to keep on doing it over
and over and over again rescuing us from
the cliff as we do you rescues us and
then we just run right back to it and
over and over and over again
so there's almost no point in a miracle
until we have courage only courageous
Christians
can maintain and defend a Christian
culture
and only courageous Christians deserve
to have a Christian culture
so we right now have the culture that we
deserve and it is a really terrible
awful ugly culture
if we want to change it we just we got
to have some guts we got to stop being
wimps to put it more simply
you
that's our hope is in having just a
little bit of courage and a good you
know the good thing is considering were
not under violent persecution
and nobody is out there threatening to
kill us or whatever if we if we stand
for our faith the worst possible thing
we could lose is our jobs which is I'm
not downplaying that but that's nothing
compared to losing your life considering
that it doesn't we don't really need to
have a lot of courage we don't need to
have the same amount of courage that you
need to have if you if you want to be a
Christian in Afghanistan or Syria that
requires a lot of courage
that requires like this much courage we
need to have only like this much this is
this is how much courage we all need to
have if we all had this much courage
I think everything could change
so that's all just that much
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed